since i began studying higher education
i've seen a lot of myths about student
debt let's dispel
three of them myth number one federal
student loans are only used by
low-income people to afford
college in fact the most well-off
households take on the highest levels of
student debt
that's because they attend expensive
colleges stay in school longer for
graduate and professional degrees
and they use low-cost government
financing over paying with cash
myth number two unaffordable student
debt is inescapable
since 2009 the federal government has
allowed borrowers to reduce their
monthly payments to an amount that's
affordable relative to their income
creating an effective safety net myth
number three
high balances are the norm while the
media tells horror stories about
white-collar professionals
struggling with loan repayment the vast
majority of borrowers have small
balances
and reasonable payments relative to
their income there is room for
improvement in the current system
but misunderstandings should be
clarified so that we don't encourage
support for illogical
or misplaced policies what do you think
needs to be improved
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like us to cover
in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei